- Ken and I both listen
carefully on our shows,
The Masked Singer and The Voice,
but how well can we identify the sounds
made by everyday objects?
Probably not well,
I'm not great at this.
It's time to find out with
the game we first played
with Emily Blunt for her movie,
A Quiet Place.
We liked it so much.
My producers love humiliating me.
So we figured what the hell,
let's do it again.
(audience laughing)
This is "A Quiet Case".
(audience clapping and cheering)
♪ A quiet case ♪
♪ Shh ♪
(hosts laughing)
- Jessie!
- [Jessie] It's an invisible case!
- It's quiet, it's quiet.
We're fun,
we're clever.
(Ken laughing)
- First, we need a host though.
And for that, we have one of the best,
our friend, Matt Iseman everybody!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
- I love this bromance!
Okay, tell us how the game works.
- So this is "A Quiet Case".
You'll get to choose a
case, I will bring it out.
There are microphones here.
I will use the item inside.
When you think you know what it is,
buzz in and answer.
If you get it right, you get the point.
If not, your opponent can steal.
- Okay, I like that you're
already thinking I'm gonna win.
Okay, I like it. Project
it! Project it! Okay.
- This is so authoritarian,
can you repeat it again for me please?
- So one more time, choose a case.
Remember the steals are allowed.
Now, Ken, you are playing
for the men in the audience.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- What's up?
What's up?
Playing for the men!
- And Kelly's playing for the ladies!
- Exactly! Exactly!
- We're in trouble, Ken.
Alright Kelly, it's your house,
you choose the first case.
- Oh, okay.
I'm gonna go with 2.
- 2 it is.
- Okay.
(Kelly sighing)
(audience cheering)
Ladies, I'm sorry.
This is not my forte.
- Silence.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Now Kelly-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You and Ken can both buzz in when
you think you know what this item is
that I will use now.
(plastic popping)
- [Mark] Kelly!
- Hairbrush?
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Like a hairbrush.
- Hairbrush, that is incorrect.
Ken, you can...
(plastic popping)
- Sounds like the bristles!
- Oh, it's like the little popper things
on the popping thing.
- Bubble wrap it is!
(audience cheering)
(energetic music)
- I'm so bad at this!
- Ken Jeong is money!
(Kelly laughing)
(audience clapping)
- I'm gonna strut!
I'm gonna strut!
Every time I win, I'm gonna strut.
- Oh my god!
Wait, I just remembered something!
Wait, I remembered.
I think last time I played this game,
I thought everything was a hairbrush!
- [Mark] You did. You
did, and as I recall,
you lost that time.
But,
Ken, you got 1 point, and it's your turn.
- Put the man in the house!
- Everything sounds like a hairbrush!
- [Mark] Ken-
- The bristles.
- [Ken] Yes sir.
- [Mark] Choose your case.
- Uh, Number..
- [Audience Member] 4!
- Don't tell me what to do!
(Kelly laughing)
4!
(crowd and hosts laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
I'm not good at this!
- [Ken] All right.
- Once again, buzz in
when you think you know
what it is I'm using.
(tense music)
(stapler clacking)
(buzzer dinging)
- [Mark] Kelly buzzed in.
- Is it a keyboard,
like you're on a keyboard?
- [Mark] It is not a keyboard.
- Jesus, take the wheel!
- Can I hear the sound again?
- [Mark] One more time.
(stapler clacking)
- Do you know this?
I can't stand you right now, Jessie.
- We need an answer, Ken,
we need an answer!
- Hairbrush?
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(buzzer ringing)
- It was a stapler!
- [Ken] Stapler?
- [Kelly] I'm not good at this!
- Which, wait, no, no,
hairbrush in Korean is stapler.
(crowd laughing)
So, put the man in the house!
2-nothing in my head.
(Kelly laughing)
- It is 2-nothing in Ken's head,
1-nothing in the real world.
Kelly, your choice for the next case.
- Oh my god, 3!
- [Mark] 3!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Aw, I'm not good at this!
I'm not good at this.
- Alright, here we go.
I'm going to, no cheating looking at me!
I'm gonna put this right
up next to the microphone
so you can hear.
- [Ken and Kelly] Okay.
- Don't yell it out, crowd.
- [Ken] Okay.
(zipper zipping)
(buzzer dinging)
- [Mark] Oh, Kelly-
- Zipper!
(bell dings)
- [Mark] Is it, a zipper!
- Oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
(audience cheering)
I got one!
- Whoa!
- I got one.
- How dare you?
- Whatever.
- I would never do that to you.
- [Kelly] 1 to 1!
- Wow.
- 1 to 1 brother.
- It is 1 to 1 and Ken, it is your choice.
- 8!
- 8.
- 8, that's a great number.
That's a good number.
- How dare you?
(Kelly laughing)
How dare you?
The game should be called "How Dare You?".
- I'm gonna strut again.
You should hold it close to the mic again.
That worked for me.
- Okay.
And with the score 1 to 1,
here is your next item.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(tense music)
(object crunching)
(buzzer dinging)
- Ken buzzed, Ken buzzed
in, it's not lighting up.
- Uh, velcro?
(buzzer ringing)
- [Mark] It is not Velcro, Kelly?
- How dare you?
(audience laughing)
- Kelly, you wanna hear it one more time?
- Yeah, one more time.
I think I know what it is
cause your mouth's full,
so wait.
(chips crunching)
I'm gonna say chips, like a chip bag
or some chips.
- Judges?
Tortilla chips!
(Kelly shouting)
(bell dinging)
- That's what I'm talkin' about.
That's what I'm talkin' about.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, oh, oh, oh!
- What is this?
- Time is up!
That means Kelly got the winner's throne!
- Yes!
(audience cheering and clapping)
Yes!
- No!
No!
- But Kelly didn't just win for herself.
- No!
- [Kelly] Alright.
- Kelly didn't just win for herself,
she won for all the ladies!
(audience cheering)
- But you know how we do things here
instead as a prize.
Everyone's getting the prize!
(audience cheering)